- Hey, it's me Destin.
Welcome back to "Smarter Every Day."
As long as I've understood the physics,
I've wanted to visualize the Shock Wave
on the front of a super sonic bullet.
But the problem with doing this,
is you have to have access
to some pretty expensive optical hardware.
Which is why I'm pretty excited
about this giant 16" parabolic mirror.
Which is going to let us play around
with the speed of sound.
Let's go get "Smarter Every Day".
Okay, We're going to use a Schlieren Setup
to get these bullet images.
Here's how it works.
So we have the camera right here, right.
So this is a Phantom v2511.
We have a mirror way over there
and the way we're doing that
is that we have a point source here.
So we're shining that light
and it's spreading out;
and as it spreads out it hits this mirror,
and it bounces back
and as it bounces back,
it comes down to a point.
One point right there
and we're cutting off half of that light.
Long story short it comes right here
flips back over goes into the lens.
If the air is less
dense then light travels
through it faster.
If air is more dense light
travels through it slower,
that causes the light to move or bend,
as it goes through different types of air;
and then we can detect those shadows
using this Schlieren Setup.
This is my buddy Coop.
He's gonna shoot through his own shop.
We're not gonna do this, you know
(cow mooing)
- I'm not shooting at his shop.
I think we're ready.
- On target.
- Three, Two, One.
Fire.
(gunshot)
Whoo huhu
(gun clicks)
- Weapon Clear.
- That's a big boom.
So let's see if we got it.
(laughing)
- [Male] Come here Coop
- [Destin] Oh Coop, come look at this.
(sound wave)
- [Male] Oh Cool
- [Destin] That's unbelievable.
Okay, so I'm gonna save that.
I like to guess where the
shock waves come from.
The initial one looks like its
coming off the bullet itself.
But then later there
seems to be this weak one
that I'm guessing that
reflected from the plywood table
that the mirror is sitting on.
Not really sure about that.
But then there's this stronger
one that comes after that
and my guess for that one
is that it's coming
off the concrete floor,
because it's more of a pure reflection.
Then later if you fast forward the video
you can see there's a very
week shock wave coming across,
and my guess is that's coming
from the muzzle itself.
I'm not sure on all these.
I canna have to extrapolate,
but that's kinda part of the fun.
Three, Two, One.
Fire.
(gunshot)
(laughing)
(sound waves)
That's legit man.
Okay so we've dropped it to
28 thousand frames per second.
We're trying to get a
really good single image.
Fire.
(gunshot)
(coughing)
I actually put air in my lungs.
(sound waves)
This footage looks amazing.
But to understand exactly
what we're looking at
why don't we build a little bitty model
with a bullet and a stick
and talk about it here.
So lets imagine that we've
got this bullet sitting here
and we've got circles
emitting from the front.
As we move this thing watch what happens.
Those circles will stack up in the front
and they kind of relax in the
back and they expand, right.
So that's a normal flight.
What happens if the velocity
at which we move thing,
out runs those circles moving away?
Check this out.
As we start to out run it,
you'll notice that we this
expansion in the back here
and it tapers down and we get this angle.
We get this, I don't know what
you'd want to call it, right.
We've got a cone here.
What happens if we move
forward even faster?
(whooshu)
That angle that we made there
is even shallower or pointier.
That's called the Mach Angle
and people use that to
measure the exact velocity
of a bullet traveling through air.
There's a simple equation.
The Mach number is equal to
one over sine of that angle
and you can figure out
how fast it's moving.
I use the circle illustration
because that's the way I was
taught in my Aerodynamic book.
But if you look at the high speed imagery,
you can actually see circles
being formed at regular intervals.
I don't understand what they
are, but they clearly there.
What we're about to do
is what I've wanted to do
from the day I understood
what Schlieren Imagery was.
We're going to shoot a Subsonic
and a Supersonic round,
and we're going to compare the
difference in the shock wave.
Coop, whatta we have?
- [Coop] So this is a 300 blackout.
- [Destin] If I understand correctly.
The whole point of this particular round
is to keep it Subsonic.
- Correct.
[Destin] This is a heavier bullet.
- This is a by 100 grains.
Almost twice the weight
of this bullet here,
and so this bullet right here
you'll get somewhere
around 1080 feet per second
at the muzzle.
Whereas this bullet right here
will give you somewhere in
the neighborhood of 1500.
[Destin] Do you know what
the sound of speed is?
- Yeah, it's like 12 something.
[Destin] I don't know.
We'll put it on the screen, right here.
That's the speed of sound.
So this one above the
sound, that one's below.
All this is on purpose because that weapon
and that cartridge design
was made specifically
because of these physics.
- So lets do Supersonic first.
- [Coop] Sure.
- Okay.
Three, Two, One.
Fire.
(gunshot)
(sound waves)
This shock wave looks
very similar to the 50 cal
with one major difference.
The angle is more Obtuse which
indicates that the bullet
is traveling much slower.
So he's chambering a Subsonic round now
and so on the Schlieren we should see
a drastically different image.
Two, One.
(gunshot)
(sound waves)
It looks like, it looks like(laughing)
- [Coop] (laughing) I can
make it, I can make it.
(sound waves)
- [Destin] Alright, so
this is a Subsonic bullet.
So why I we seeing these
little flickery things
on the side of the bullet?
That doesn't make a lot of sense to me.
So this what I always do
in a situation like this.
I went looking for expert,
which lead me to Dr. Kanistras.
A well respected aerodynamics professor
at University of Alabama in Huntsville.
One thing we saw on the Subsonic bullet
is we see, we didn't see that shock wave
but we saw these weird lines
out to the side of the bullet, you know.
- [Dr. Kanistras] What is the
speed, when you say Subsonic?
- [Destin] It's about 10 percent less
than the speed of sound.
- You have Supersonic flow there.
It's a Normal Shock.
What you see there.
- [Destin] On a Subsonic bullet?
- Uh-huh, what is happening
on a commercial aircraft?
It goes between point
eight to one point two.
Even if you're flying Subsonic,
you have acceleration of the flow.
So you're reaching one point two.
- [Destin] What?
- Then you going back Subsonic.
- [Destin] So what you're
saying is even though I have,
- [Dr. Kanistras] It's a Normal Shock.
- [Destin] I have a Subsonic bullet
but the speed of the air
is Supersonic right there,
half way up the bullet.
So on this Subsonic bullet,
those things I'm seeing,
you're saying that's Supersonic flow.
- That's right.
- [Destin] And it's because the air
has to move out of the
way around the bullet.
So it has to accelerate.
- That's right, yeah
- [Destin] Really.
- So the flow accelerates, and
creates a Normal Shock there.
- [Destin] It's because
this particular bullet
is so close to the speed of sound.
- It reaches a transsonic speed,
which is point eight to one point two.
So even if it's not
supersonic at this point,
at some point on the surface
it will become Supersonic.
- [Destin] That's cool.
Thank you.
(laughs)
That's really cool.
Thank you for explaining that.
After this we decided to
move closer to the mirror,
so we could see what the muzzle blast
(gunshot)
from the weapon itself look like.
(sound waves)
After that we moved the
muzzle back about a foot
so we could see that transition period
(gunshot)
where that bullet pierces
through the blast itself.
What's even more impressive
is each one of those
tiny grains of propellant
had that visible shock wave
you could see associated with it.
(sound waves)
One more thing real quick,
we took video of revolver.
It literally leaks shock
waves out of the side.
But before I show you that
I want to say thank to the
sponsor which is Audible.
Audible has been a partner for
"Smarter Every Day" forever,
and I'm very grateful because
I enjoy getting smarter
by listening to books as I drive.
This is like the perfect
Brand match for me.
It helps me get smarter everyday.
You can get free book by
going to audible.com/smarter
or text in the word "smarter" to 500 500.
I've a special book to recommend today.
It's called "THEM, Why we hate
each other and how to heal,"
and it's by Senator Ben Sasse.
I steer really far away
from politics at all times,
but this is not a political book.
It's about the things that are
eroding away at our culture.
Things like loneliness
and the importance of your
family support structure,
and how we need a scape goat;
and sometimes we get
angry at other people.
when the problem is things
that we are doing in own life.
It's a really good book.
So I highly recommend it.
I'm not quite done with
it, but up to this point
it seems to be apolitical.
So check that out.
"THEM, why we hate each
other and how to heal."
You ca get that by going
to audible.com/smarter
or texting the word "smarter" to 500 500.
It's about how we can improve ourselves
by working on our communities around us.
I really like it,
and now definitive scientific proof
of why your hands should never
leave the grip of a revolver.
One.
(gunshot)
(sound waves)
One.
(gunshot)
- Weapons clear.
- [Destin] That is the best video
I've probably ever participated in.
(sound waves)
Look at that, oh my goodness.
Okay, well I've a feeling we're going
to be doing something like this again.
Can you see us stopping at this?
- No.
- Okay.
- No way.
- Yeah , so there you go.
Feel free to subscribe
to "Smarter Every Day"
if you're into this kind of thing.
If you're not, I don't know
what's wrong with you (laughs).
That's amazing.
Alright, cool, thanks.